give me the word you guys ready right
now we're ready brother we're ready my
friend eat chicken monday oh you really
Monday I want to thank Tampa for coming
out in force
how was Cherokee buddy atomic Cherokee
Casino first of all did you see the
static solemn solemn Springs
it sounds alarm swamps long some of the
best coffee in the world best coffee
break our John yep poor John's can I get
my girl Lacey's the Beast over there
bring in real comics yep good crowd
yep who's Jays birthday yup and his
birthday is Jay's birthday yeah I do
with me in Oklahoma
he got Yeezy so and they got him a cake
that's very nice there we cake three
obviously the organic yes good that
snapping turtle I've seen what happened
yeah - where where did you see the snap
did you see all snaps I kill them
Brennan boy revenged
i reaiiy figure is the best thing you
Avengers remember revenged him pissing
on you laughs I remember he pissed peed
well he peed on the guy's leg but
nobody's brain on direction it was in my
direction some of it I found that stupid
turtle turtle Pitts might have given me
psoriasis that's what I'm thinking on
your legs
so would you I killed him you slew the
turtle mm-hmm how did you kill it
what Oh No hi there how I kicked them
Brendon we're in the shower in the face
and the tail oh man that's a terrible
way to talk that in you can't tuck the
tail then tuck the tail you just kept
matching his tail kill them and then I
kill his stupid owner for being that guy
that's not a good fight cuz he can't
probably he's so heavy he pad - did you
kill him sitting down though I held the
turtle i chomped his throat you held the
turtles this on his throat that's got a
hug a lawnmower
that's gotta hurt they missed you in
Oklahoma though Arkansas they might be
doing it right out there man they've all
that land it's beautiful that is a
beautiful little talent I don't know
what you 70 people will you get your
friends you'd have to find good you you
have to find yourself a girl that you
really loved make a bunch of kids it'd
have a bunch of kids you'd have a couple
dogs I want mine up there's a farm you
get a farm you get yourself some animals
you grow your own food you grow your own
animals that's what I would do you know
you can you can buy baby cows like they
stay baby like miniature cows
what's so bad no that's not - I looked
up
Santa Monica found upon their let me see
let me see a baby cow bring up don't
bring baby cow miniature cow
of course it's baby cows organ time yeah
there's no way there are miniature cows
I promise broken or not in not Santa
Monica buddy I just know I'm Sayla
Moloch for God's sakes I said Oh Monica
that's where I live chin
man you're cute as [ __ ] right hold on
black one yeah there they go they're
adorable ya fluffy Minnie cows are you
kidding me no let's get one I would love
to have one of those look how sweet they
are at home you can own a fluffy mini
cow oh my god they're cute look at their
eyes honey bro look at those noses
they're [ __ ] adorable can you milk
them and get milk from them Alice no
Ukraine cuties I know that whales
radicular welcome bro so wait so I want
to move somewhere with a lot of land he
could even be start with Santa Barbara
let's have a shitload of mini cows and I
could get myself some some mini mini
jugs of milk listen bro we're trying to
melt these goddamn things that's so cute
though dude I was watching on the plane
ride over to Arkansas I was watching
Bear Grylls
yeah things you know Bill Bear Grylls is
he was a former SAS commando so he has
that survival show but I does it with
celebrities he did that the kid three
three words
Jordan Lovitz whatever Joseph
gordon-levitt George what is it Joseph
gordon-levitt worst Joseph gordon-levitt
yes they did with him yeah
that [ __ ] was amazing really here in
Africa there in South Africa Africa so
he takes all you know he just pairs up
with celebrities now yeah piers up with
him and I'm like eh this should be
alright and then they're climbing
through dogs you focus on we're going on
400 podcasts it's all good and so his
but I didn't know Joseph his brother
died of an overdose but they touch on it
and he gets like super hard fouls again
I'm about to cry on this goddamn plane
yeah yeah so they start B he goes I
don't like to talk about it on TV
especially goes but when I was going
through the thick of it you know it
might it helped me to hear other people
talk about so I'll talk about I've never
known this he talks about and then he
has beer Eagles you ever lost me
yeah I lost my dad when I was young and
so they start going back forth so I'm on
the plane I'm like goddamn choking up
and then it gets fun though because
they're climbing right and they go to
like this
thank you this rock thing and there's
like a big like puddle right and there's
a dead [ __ ] water buffalo face down
dead in the water
and beers like oh that's good meat
because that heads not in the Sun so we
like to eat to get the tongue or the
nose what eat that but you can't eat the
meat because that needs to meet kiss all
filled maggots in the Sun it's rot so
you can't eat the meat so you guys will
get the nose or the the tongue will cut
it and Joseph is like Jesus Christ man I
guess I won't do that and Joseph goes to
step down and I don't think they can
script this you go step down here don't
go in that water is why this watch this
he was I guess it's not guaranteed with
already something that takes a stick
those they're a [ __ ] giant croc holy
yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
what so he goes hold this and goes hold
this and it's like a big branch with a
fork in it you just hold this here I'm
gonna go around then you go around so
you go around and he goes we're still
gonna get that water buffalo had because
we need that tongue they lifted up
there's like maggots on the tongue and
then the nose she's like we can still
cook it so they like [ __ ] bears
wrestling with the Gator like this hold
him there while Joseph yeah with the
crocodile yeah it's just keeping that
baby cuz he's they're stealing its food
so it's [ __ ] pissed and so they take
this big cow's tongue cut it off putting
his backpack and they eat it they kind
of need to see this is there any way we
can see that Park for the quest called
runnin wild with Bear Grylls it's [ __ ]
get there this [ __ ] fire starting
with Joseph's brothers Joseph
gordon-levitt clip one did I want to see
this I don't think you want to see right
I just type the [ __ ] up all the same
talk about his brother done was he's
amazing actor by the way oh yeah sorry
when he was six
really
I would tell myself don't force anything
and and don't resist anything if you're
gonna feel sad then go ahead and feel it
don't try to resist that mmm but then
they're all it's just about him talk
about his brother guy in this part so
he's got a stronger face there that's a
that's a weather-beaten face yes you've
been in some conditions bro he's been in
some conditions faces out to be honest
though my face exhibit look well
fighters I noticed a fleet guys a lot of
guys like I saw Donald Cerrone I love
him but Donald look looks every bit my
age cuz he's got those Donald line face
looks like in the Indy person's back I
saw him with a cowboy hat on that at the
fight and I'm like that my man has got
some deep line that's issue bruh yeah
your face yeah that's a man's face hard
life hard face hard life hard face hard
like I say about girls that's right
buddy yeah hard life hard face sometimes
a hard face can turn me on cuz I'm like
you've been here here it is okay so
we're gonna fight you like this part
Joseph he wants them to climb down he
goes you should be fine Justin goes I
don't play that game am I gonna be good
going down or not man yeah because he's
like you should be are a ghost no no I
don't play by those I will look out for
my health I'm not going down for am I
gonna be fine I would love for me I take
to the know I look for you near you know
at the end of the day is we're not
famous enough
that's it you have over you have a point
I have to first exclude you the people
that have on the order of it I have to
explain my what I do
why would I do and here's why I'm kind
of a celebrity but not really count
about it like do you listen to the
fighter in Decatur who get the guess he
has on it's like I'd love to do that but
we're not famous enough plus I wouldn't
need him I take to a while so how much
we know you'd want it so fun keep it the
picture up and a he'll cut it it's quite
nerve-wracking if you've never danced
before now you'd get some heat for
having like craft services no because
they said when he had his show remember
there's him and there's that other dudes
about that other dudes I accept the
cameras go back and get [ __ ] you that
was so boring yeah that guy was so
boring option value yeah I need some
entertain
I forget the guys know so it's not let's
try let's try out some oh oh god that's
a carcass that's what we're smelling
that really smells yeah I think I can
safely say that is the worst smell I've
ever experienced in my life in my life
yeah without a close second it's a
buffalo let you see its head I love that
putrifying guts you see that yeah look
like black garbage bags full of blood
oh the mega tried you can't script this
I'm not gonna take no rips it apart then
everything else starts moving in on it
that's incredible
just makes feel a little bit suspicious
so you see that look no I didn't see it
unless I'm seeing things maybe I'm
seeing things
no sir they were gonna cross that water
their plan was to go through them dude
that's such a small pond because you
realized you're dealing with something
it's a lot more powerful and a lot more
that be so game over then we are well
that's a crocodile he's feeding on that
black boys be feeding off all this stuff
and he's literally like the happiest guy
around he's gonna be not moving from
here for a long time okay well that's a
crocodile how big is he can't stop
bitching people won't be able to Marius
okay there's that stuff here that's a
croc in that good though yeah don't [ __ ]
around with Crocs
I want bear to take me out man um in
South Africa though I don't want to go
somewhere lame like California so like
yeah I'd go take you Nevada I'll tell
you one of the coolest things I've ever
done those were thirsty I was in this
Sahara Nevada Sierra Nevada severe
Nevada the Sierra and the Sierra the
Sahara is a desert that's right oh I
wouldn't I went to bolt so what's your
[ __ ] you did you notice the Sahara
hold on everybody I need to now see this
is where we get excited and we
overcompensate and we say something
sometimes pops out of our out that we
didn't mean so I can't I can't put the
toothpaste back in the tube now ask me
again
yeah did you go to the Sahara Desert
Brennan
where's that okay see now now you know
yours that though now you're stalling I
know but don't say you went to the
Sahara is that it that would be in
Africa the effort that's in the Africa
the continent so oh I think I heard you
say you'd been to the um sorry I get
that confused with Nevada Nevada I see
you're talking about four years Nevada
you tell me you have an accent like
Africa
Nevada I said Africa yeah I'm sorry all
right yeah yeah yeah no I was in Africa
but I when I did that similar thing but
it was like no territory and we're up in
those mountains it's one of the coolest
things I've ever done man well I heard
from a little birdie just a little
birdie that you had to run a
special-forces obstacle course six miles
sir and you had six miles and you had
how much weight on your back some like
85 pounds 85 pounds and I think that you
I think
yeah this is what I heard for somebody
else that you broke the record for it
people over 220 pounds you're being very
quiet right now you're being now that's
your looking over your not looking at me
it sounds like that's true but you're
trying to be modest
maybe man that's my dude in these shoes
I know you didn't I'm dying it's [ __ ]
cool up there though man we need to do
more nature stuff I agree dude go
camping let's ditch our family I just
loved in camp with you you and I well we
need to start we we blowin up you sent
me those those pictures and that video
of us when we were doing fight earning
kids dude how about I was looking
through my pictures
cuz I you posted something what did you
still of you and I and one of our
sketches where I'm selling you for money
oh that's right and I was like dude and
then I went back because I was like oh
that's hilarious um and I went back and
I got the video of the highlight of
finding kid 3d yeah how funny was that
what was so funny he was like ages ago
it does and we had so much fun we got to
get back to that and I'm say that's
right now you do it huh we're gonna
figure out a way to get back to it so
you have to do some stuff problems you
get very busy we both get very busy
right so I was telling we're both liked
on our own lanes we can still do it well
we could still do 100% but we could do
it and do it right cuz not that it
wasn't done right last time but now I
mean we could show them the success if I
don't get 3d you could go in any [ __ ]
big Pichet production place hit Jane
would buy it yeah anyone yeah and and
especially well since I see a is gonna
hear this and make up that's what we're
doing I know we just do it on hide get
some [ __ ] smart funny he's got it out
in two weeks 100% and kill it just fully
involved the although call those guys
why not in all those guys be sure I do
it huh well I don't know we have access
to the funniest people in the world they
all have a following we could do some
crazy fun it's just it won't cost us
anything cuz you could just take the the
you show the production team their
numbers of what we did last time that's
right that's right say suck in limbo
suck on them bow bow bow bow Oh aren't
you suck on him bow them balls today
when I was in Tampa and I was me there
before one person
with the park and there was a there was
a creek and there's a big old sign said
beware of alligators at anywhere in
Florida if it's a high of water
get away you'll rest pull rectly cat
away put any body of water flora I do
not enter that's right I assume there's
a giant going on all of them it's like
going Nick Swardson said there's a gator
over there careful when you take a piss
[ __ ] that Gator never seen never seen
again said dad it was like really yeah
oh really
you want to mess with a dinosaur dude
with a dragon okay I'm literally a
dragon well once they grow like Tampa
though I like that area yeah me too I
like it a lot too
it's it's the women there take their
exercise very seriously I was in
Gulfport Florida in general you want
their gold I don't know oh into a
powerhouse gym I'm in a body building
now so I I crank out body parts crank it
out and I until it until I exhaust the
muscle eight small protein meals every
day so if I come in here and I start
looking more and more buff in 51
dude I'm Sam's little bro yeah I'm
starting to isolate how's your psoriasis
is he gun never been worse but that's a
whole different story you'll figure it
out yes sometime for your special yeah
it's okay that's because I well my
psoriasis is great and then when I dis
what I do I go I'm gonna have Indian
food I'm gonna have magic in doing that
and mix a bunch I'm like you know what I
think all the guys and then good like
impotent airboy skin goes cuckoo she
makes him tempeh I have a Mexican before
that problem the autoimmune is if you
eat something like four days later it's
like guys yeah it's okay it's just a
conditioner what you do for the fourth I
did nothing ice at home with my family
would you do even relaxed
party you partied big party remember
fireworks
yeah the illegal fire well was it you
have any video or anything on my
Instagram but that's purlin that's it
bring em bro can I see one thing about
fireworks no big deal but God will see a
lot of them I'm over right and so when
bill woo
I've seen a lot of them in my life in
them all they're all the same they are
all the same
how are you not improved I don't know
the one thing those put time into human
bodies in the air then I doubt with that
I would want something out of cannons
where's the video on your fourth party
dude the fourth
so it's it's different because it's
right in front of us right like on the
driveway with these huge a massive like
that out raising loud fire that's just
right in front of us and notice it's
pretty cool when you I that's pretty
cool I'm saying behind cuz I'm don't if
you go back and watch 1983 fireworks
they look exactly the same
they've never grown well there's never
made an advance they have governor's on
I love this to a my neighbor who loves
this and he will he has this place in
Nevada where he goes well you got to do
a winding road and you got to get this
you know and they they sell semi illegal
fireworks and he'll come back with
$1,200 worth and he used to set him off
right in the middle of our street but
with mortars but that you know cops were
fine
they're all the same can't do the same
they're all the [ __ ] same they've
never you're still gonna get just fire
truck firecrackers have never gotten
better they do flags now have you seen
it work blows up and it turns yeah I saw
that was an 8th grade son really yeah
thank you like designs I've seen pop-up
and then that's kind of it'll be like a
say something more like happy 4th or
flat pretty impressive but they've never
really you know like the shiny stuff
folks and on approach check this out
real quick well I get a kick out of up
BAM
holy [ __ ] that's the United States flag
er that's come on [ __ ] no you're not
and I'm not a patriot but that's a mess
oh dude speaking of not being a patriot
I brought you up during my bit I do a
reference to you and some dude who's
actually I think is a psychology
professor damn goes big gay eagle and I
have to come to a screeching halt on it
what did you say anyone starts ever he
goes big gay you know it well well no
bro you work it's goddamn almost it's
just barely after the fourth you know on
American edits it's the big gay al Brody
laughs BK Eagle so that some Isis
propaganda bro he's laughing oh yeah
that's so funny I bet my I cannot stop
laughing all night there's well I'll get
when people can take pictures of me it's
always a young dude who goes and it's
always like this usually it's a bunch
guys go
psoriasis kid that's my new nickname
this arises kid then other man I the kid
and then I'll get a straggler once a
while ago I wanted to get a picture with
the big old gay out oh my that's too
much syrup in your voice and you're
getting way too close to me for this
selfie oh brother
and why are you the last guy in line to
get a little extra time with me they
don't want to guess
you know there's always that guy who's
just hanging around he's just waiting
for the line to dissipate huh just makes
us you just see him lingering he's like
a man mind if I take a picture with the
big gay al know what's going on with all
the syrup in your bowl or or the guy go
where you going after this bro that's a
good this is that man going in my room
yeah I sent you that text ring calm
comes over and goes he goes bro I've
seen you I think I know you are right
and I go I'm eating I'm waiting for my
I'm in Atlanta I'm waiting to get on my
plane and I'm eating my rice and chicken
and oh my God Jesus Christ okay that's
all good I love it you know it's very
nice but he's like he's like and I know
he knows me but he's trying to get you
nothing worse and he goes yep that's it
yeah I'm a fan bro love I listen to the
podcast bro let me ask you so
Los Angeles and I'll leave you alone I
don't want to bother you of course you
mind if I take a seat oh okay he's got
all his bags he won't take off his body
so I'm already exhausted I'm already
exhausted or he has gotten satchels he's
got something strapped across his body
then good thing that he's got a plastic
bag I'm like you look like you're
literally on a long march and you're
trying to hold like carry yeah and a bat
he's got a he's got a bunch of sticks on
his back I'm like what is going on here
dude and he's and he's looking at me and
he goes um he goes and he's got baggy
shorts with flip-flops the whole thing's
a disaster and he goes I want to ask you
guys can I borrow I'll leave you alone
after this mind if I said good hey
listen do you know of any good Mort I
James in Los Angeles because I want to
bring my my kick game up on the ground
and pound I want to bring my kick game
in line with my ground I go I do know of
a lot of Muay Thai gyms in Los Angeles
in fact here's Brendon child's my boy he
would love to hold mitts for you and
hold a kicking pad for you and also just
throw a stick and you'll hit a Muay Thai
gym literally also it doesn't really
matter for you that's it you just keep
walking around with all that weight on
your body and you'll be very strong some
people are just you know so far is
though oh my god is hilarious it's
[ __ ] hilarious you know what I got
into is it's on A&E it's on demand it's
uh the god father and son it's about
John Gotti oh and it's about his son
yeah the story is all about it's us he
goes into John Gotti's story and all
that but you know John Gotti want his
son to take over form and son didn't
want to live that life right so there's
video was one of the sons was killed
what if some just killings young though
yeah but then yeah by a car he got hit
by a car and they killed that guy that
guy disappeared you know that but do you
know why he disappeared so there was
their next-door neighbor so is there
behind neighbor you know so the their
backyard they share the backyard with so
that man ran over John Gotti son yeah
hit him on a bike yeah so the mom wanted
deep depression she was so mad at that
guy but they understood it was on
whatever and then he was thrown a big
party a huge party two years later
throwing a huge party
the mom goes how can he just continue
with life and be happy in the music's
blaring so she goes over there to tell
him to shut the [ __ ] up and you kill my
son he shouldn't allowed to have you
know happiness and how can you do this
like we're right here you know what
we're going through ya do this and he
goes well your son should have been in
that part of the [ __ ] Street should he
and she goes okay goes home and tells
John Gotti the two days later I thought
man Hotel hasn't been found I didn't
know that yet I didn't know that that's
what happened that's what so they gave
him a pass on that cuz it was an
accident gave him a pass in the name of
the mom the mom went over there went and
I don't think it was I'm sorry was like
months after he killed the kid the party
was months not years uh-huh see our mom
goes how the [ __ ] can you do this we're
grieving you're throwing a [ __ ] party
having drinks and then she like tried to
him with a bat
she didn't wanted to [ __ ] kill him
and he goes you're [ __ ] you should
watch it kid closer he shouldn't be in
the middle of the road like that and
then she said that's all she didn't hear
she put the bat down went okay alright
man and when told John Gotti then all of
a sudden days later homeboys just gone
forever I would have been I would have
moved like a bomb him at a respect no I
I would have moved just I wouldn't want
to be a visual reminder of the the
deepest sorrow for a party I def
Porteous poor taste where you can hear
it well customs life done whatever I
could to me but it's pretty fascinating
cuz they go into John Gotti house just
this ruthless like street thug and he
took over and he was like a street guy
and then his son didn't grow up that way
and you know his son wanted to be just
like his father and thought it was all
cool and then they even you know kind of
got him into it and then he was like man
this does not end well for anyone he has
kids he's like do I want to see my kids
[ __ ] live man I don't this ain't the
life so they have it's pretty
fascinating they have it of him when his
father was in prison for life right you
want to wait for life and his cancer of
the mouth his mouth cancer and he's
still getting it you know he's in a
wife-beater and still [ __ ] John Gotti
yeah he still running [ __ ] in the prison
yeah and his son goes in to see him and
he has to tell his father that he
doesn't want to be in the Mafia anymore
and the dad just [ __ ] I mean do they
have it all on tape just shits on him
he's a key why what are you talking
about right now and
goes on this whole rant like on a how
big of a [ __ ] move it is and that's not
what they stand for and it's very easy
man well cuz I know I knew Bruce Cutler
who was his lawyer through the whole
thing on Gotti's yeah he's on there and
Bruce Cutler was talking about great guy
by the way funny
I had long talks him he was also he was
also defending Phil Spector
I mean he's and he said I've he said I
have I have defended some very
formidable men and he was a wrestler too
by big boy a big big strong guy himself
and he goes I've defended some very
formidable men and he really lived it he
really was the guy I got it yeah he
wouldn't open his mouth he did that
America thing that that silence you know
America that that tie-in word for keep
your mouth shut but Sammy the bull when
he when he spit when he talked it was
bad this crazy man crazy and then like
he grew up and he's I forget his name
like big Big John or something like that
was basically the the uncle to the boys
and it's John Gotti's best friend and he
was informant for the FBI to who was
John Gotti's best friend he's informant
and he never ratted on John Gotti then
when John Gotti got pinched for one of
the things that he got off on that they
had to go to him and for him not to get
jail time he had to give up someone or
some info and he did and so he took the
boys out on his boat and who he loved he
was like their uncle and he goes you
guys know I love you right and they're
young and JA guy sons talking about this
he goes I can't understand like he's all
emotional he's like you know I love you
right like of course Big John we we love
you man what he thought we'll see you
tomorrow cuz his dad because he knew
that by letting any info out he was
[ __ ] but they the FBI go since you
gave us he wants to put you into you
know hiding like you wants to sweat this
protective protection he goes no I
talked to John he said I can't be around
the family anymore
but my safety is fine next day opens the
door 19 bullet holes to the face that's
right of course yeah you're gonna die
hard man yeah yo
snitches get stitches dude I mean you're
not you're dealing with if you want
chilling with the Casa Nostra you don't
if you watch those first 48 or any of
these mafia moves the only way the
[ __ ] good guys can do anything is by
snitches they can't get by without
witnesses they can't they with evidence
or unless it's a one-on-one murder but
it's like a domestic thing they can't
man they don't pinch anybody no is this
bright as this son now in jail John
Gotti Jr no no no he's out of the
business brother Wow yeah he got
completely out of it well do you know
you're not there's it's not it doesn't
end well right I mean the business
doesn't end well for you you're gonna
die or go to jail there's better ways to
live your life I had to look it up they
said in his first year he's making
between 12 to 20 million dollars a year
the family is worth about 500 million
yeah that's crime pays careful but they
said John Gotti and most the the Italian
mafia forever was against drugs like
yeah he's the main guy they say that
that's the the black the breakdown of
family values ironically was what would
the breakdown of the Italian mafia
because he used to be it's my
grandfather's Sicilian right yeah so and
and from Brooklyn and from and and you
couldn't be in business like my
grandfather without knowing those guys
and they were all immigrants so when my
grandfather's father came to from Italy
and and my grandmother's father came
from Italy and remember my grandfather
my grandmother they all spoke Italian
like it was there was a first night so
in when I said they were all and with it
we were all southern Italian Naples and
Sicily yeah so you couldn't be in you
couldn't be in Brooklyn you couldn't be
in New York without having grown up with
those guys
having to deal with all that stuff but
there were rules and my grandfather's
always say they'll never kill the family
he never killed a fan you killed the guy
you never killed a family that'll never
happen
yeah and also there there were just
there were hard and fast rules no drugs
there are ways to never do legging
prostitution gambling yeah but never
drop never drugs and when drugs got
involved that's what they said when they
got into heroin it was too much money
though lucky it was so [ __ ] much
money that Lucky Luciano was like the
first business businessman of the Mafia
who was like we're not connect
drugs that's right if everyone's get
pinched start [ __ ] with drugs that's
where the government does not play we're
not gonna touch drugs but then other
guys like it's too much money man lucky
Luciano's like that he's basically the
[ __ ] Steve Jobs of mafia if you watch
if you fall him off he was like he could
should be okay everybody one for you is
the main businessman behind everything
and he was there also
what since about the time mafias there
the kind of only mafia that would want
there like sons and stuff to stay in the
life like they want to hand it down to
the fin yeah so Meyer Lansky's yeah the
Jews they don't want that that's right
like no no we're bustin our asses you
don't have to do this way talent we say
you're in the family yeah
the Italians that's what they are that's
the classic difference when lucky Lucy a
Luciano and Meyer Lansky and Jewish the
Jews got into organized crime their sons
became lawyers doc with her knowledge
yeah all that stuff when where'd the
Italian yeah that's right you can sign
them up and you kept your money in a
[ __ ] mattress you didn't put it into a
legit business so this is Jameson
culture man yeah but it's obvious that's
interesting yeah but look up Lucky
Luciano if you're in the Mafia stuff
like yeah that's where it all starts
there was a way they were predictable
you you were paying money but like in in
Brooklyn in certain like Benson when you
had a pizza parlor where you were paying
money you paid Locrian overhead but it
was all predictable like so when you
when you're trash came you were paying
money you weren't gonna use any if you
weren't shopping around for the best my
buddy I remember Seth when he had this
restaurant called bubbies and it's still
there in Tribeca and this is in 1992 and
remember when Seth goes he was from Seth
was I think from Massachusetts and Seth
goes I tried to shop around for for like
when when they came to put on my garbage
I have this new business I said I'm
gonna shop around you guys I don't like
your price and the guys on the garbage
truck Oh God
we'll be back but God do it and he
called every garbage company and
everyone I mean ever they go not my
jurisdiction brother there's only one
guys again that was it it wasn't you
didn't know it was just that you're
dealing with that guy or they this would
the other thing they would do you had a
if you had a bar you had a jukebox in
your bar you just had a jukebox in your
bar that was the
well and and if you if you like Jimmy
Burks father said I don't want a Tupac's
in my bar they were like oh okay well
yarr and there'll be a guy every week
that'll come and get the money out but
we own the jukeboxes and they're in your
bar yeah and if you had a problem that
your windows got bro and the more you
just get beat up yeah not even that they
just said [ __ ] would start happening
yeah yeah
so inch don't [ __ ] around I thought was
so answer how John Gotti was like you
know he's on the front cover of time
he's on all the magazines
he was the Teflon Don he was literally
like the like a superstar like megastar
but then still was operating the biggest
crime mafia family in the world be he's
like literally you turn on the news he's
on there he's on magazine covers we used
to go to Little Italy it's almost like
is this weird to say like I almost wish
there's something like that going on now
well so we used to go to we used to go
to Little Italy okay and we used to eat
a cafe Sorrento cafes rental was right
next to the ravenite Club which was his
club okay and you'd always see him you'd
see a you see a limousine and a guy with
an earpiece there every day okay and
then you see dudes come out of there
like these rough looking dudes and all
of us would go there in the hopes of
catching a glimpse of John Gotti now
when John Gotti would eat in his
neighborhood tourists would come up
smile and ask for autographs that was a
big problem because now you're visible
you know you don't see that with the
Chinese mafia the Triads nobody oh yeah
yeah and that was a big problem is all
of a sudden now they became visible and
it was like you can't you can't become a
celebrity and I'm and a [ __ ] but
that's what happened like thinking about
with El Chapo celebrity is a
[ __ ] Mexico here obviously
everyone shoot him in the face but let's
go oh yeah you're too visible but all
those guys actor they think I'm an actor
they think I'm a monster
you know I'm saying mafia I'm doing [ __ ]
well don't say that I'm doing [ __ ] but
throughout John Gotti how big of a
celebrity was and had all these like
$3,000 shoots there's chain which isn't
that crazy but had like $2,000 suits
that's very expensive is not some myself
but the dance the John Gotti anyways but
what would be you know suits what what
is a who makes those suits about Paul
Smith no like you
my hon have a custom suit guys so they
literally come to your house you pick
out whatever fabric you want color from
the seams the button will you you have a
body that kind of needs to have a tail
no but most most people wear suits it's
all tailored most people no one's buying
it's girly it's got a bit spokes no
one's buying a suit off the rack these
days really it's called a bespoke suit
so somebody tailors it to your own
company house and then you can pick
whatever you want so what are you what
are you what what but but if you brought
an Armani suit wouldn't is that isn't
that or three four grand five grand
maybe max no that's a lot of money
that's a lot of money yeah but it's also
what you need custom ones you know your
custom so when you see LeBron James and
those guys they're wearing its offensive
yeah yeah but they did this whole
breakdown of a suit you know maybe four
or five grand it's nothing like 1520
yeah that's a lot of money for five
grand
not only you're worth 2 billion though
would you you're talking about guys were
you making twenty million dollars a year
yeah it's not that much money you're
making three million it's not the
thought I have to be honest I kind of
want to wear expensive suits right now I
want to be a gentleman it's fun picking
up the suits and all that [ __ ] yeah I'd
like to
I want bespoke pants I mean I want the
shoes and I want spokes suits and I want
to be psoriasis free I just think it's
[ __ ] crazy how big of a story was
then going through all that then even
had a hit go down because he killed the
boss sparks this sparks takes smarts
take a swab last night still there
yeah castronovo orbits is still there of
course I've eaten there good even there
many times nice it's great I've eaten
there many times I'd like to go there
next time when we used to go there all
the time I'd like to go there Castellano
Paul Castellano
remember he did that even when he was
still super famous hmm he had his guys
do that
well hit well that that's right I
remember I remember this I remember this
so well this was a big news in New York
City mess huge man yeah one with one did
he go down I think a night I want to say
1989 was in the 90s or no yeah I think
was the 80s that was a big mistake
though I guess 1977 no no it was all I
there open it I wasn't I was a senior in
high school that's right yeah 85 yeah I
remember God look to go eat there now
and then read
like all the way on the floor knee take
a picture there's that poor taste no
yeah he was he said to his nanny
he's his maid who was his housekeeper
who I think he had an affair with he
said guys like me Diane Street just LA
no yeah John Gotti killed him because he
became head of the family and John Gotti
didn't respect him because he wasn't a
street guy he's a businessman he's I
can't have a businessman run this
[ __ ] family so he killed him to
become the boss he did that wall he was
on like the front cover of time [ __ ]
when he's famous this [ __ ] yeah man it's
insane man I think it's so good you know
John Gotti the movie with John
Travolta's out right now it's under the
radar I know but it's the lowest lowest
rate oh really yeah let me see the
trailer chin it's bad because I thought
in theatres I just know it did really
poorly and it was directed by by the guy
from Entourage the kid a good guy - I
like him what's his name
let me see that trailer Jim you want to
see this off one yeah yeah please is
that the most viewed one yeah I haven't
like I saw Mike oh my god I love John
Kyle of John Travolta oh speaking of I
was a kid nice treats and I made it to
the top
I've made my bones doing a piece of
where the music is are they there enough
like that can't go unchecked
got the wrong guy man for you
Johnson has been an informant for the
music is so I want to see this as a
father the idea god that looks good to
me yeah it looks good don't they'll
double the marketing on it stare the
music is so over gaudy up it makes look
so low-budget yeah ball-ball likes not
an action movie it's like spendable 7 I
was like I think they should met oh man
they couldn't so much but really the
vibe you want it's the black mass 5 that
dark ominous
[ __ ] intense yeah music that kind of
text to do you so long that's fast this
summer there's a new bar interesting the
John Gotti interesting John Travolta
that's a good example of age difference
because that's my generation so I'm like
yeah you guys like I've seen that look
so cheesy
that looks that means you've seen it
before a lot they're just a whole whole
print all that looks so cheap you don't
like the font you don't like now oh my
god in the color he's the boss new boss
in town you son god
voiceover this summer charge of also not
taking look who's talking to he's me
with a barrel chest and small hips with
expensive - John Gotti
takes no prisoners this summer he's a
compulsive gambler if you tell on him
he'll give you a warning they don't
shoot you in the face that's all you
really dragged out your world should
have done that that makes it so much
I'll watch it what goes on demand and
illegally stream it tonight but the
thing is Brandon Brandon Brandon Conda
you know I still chin earlier I took
it's people don't talk about this cuz
whenever like we never post this but
like when it like say you're in Tampa
[ __ ] laughter this when you're in Tampa
right sold out or ever I'm in Houston or
Wilbur theater Willie's post but I'm
Friday night I sent the Icehouse
10 o'clock show set the ice house and
it's a hundred and five degrees out no
one's coming down their house
I show up and I Drive away out there and
there's seven people come out no there's
seven people and the calm is too hot the
comics are eating all the dicks in the
room like everyone's bombing of course I
wonder I still do I want to put it on my
feet and be like everyone all comics and
people talk about how glorious the Comic
Life is how good this is sometimes how
that goes down this is what we haven't
seven people and seven people and you
still got perform like this is and I
drove all the way down while your energy
body right dude
all the energy so I want to put that but
then I thought ice house would get mad
at me so I didn't do it I don't want
them back what the [ __ ] man so I didn't
post it but they might pay it can be
exhausting when that happens well I was
so watch kappa i walked in i the the
lady run that i love Franco what
happened it's one called a bomb scare
something she's like no sweetie it's the
weather
well for me I was worried about Tampa
because I told you I said at one point
in the beginning of the week like not
sold 69 tickets than 112 and it's a 350
room seat so that was I think I called
Martin Marty who's awesome but doesn't I
go dude we got to ramp up something I'm
worried about this and I thought it was
gonna be I was gonna dick sold out all
four shows because they come they come I
don't know what kind of last-minute
whatever it is but I well totally energy
and my body as I was flying out there
thinking that I was playing too I was
like I don't want to do this I want to
put comedy I'm really depressed such a
form and then when they said now we're
sold out we're gonna sell out I called
you I text you you go [ __ ] I got no
I think it's true and I was like whoa
okay then you got seven people in a room
how many times did I play that no but
throughout the year it's not my [ __ ]
it's not my show that's not my thing
when you doing such and trying to work
on stuff and you go in town to TAS a
long drive yeah well I don't mind the
drive I thought it's funny like I don't
post that stuff house club in the
country yep older than anything in New
York though you said all this comedy
club yeah but New York's gotta have the
older that it's gotta be older New York
to Chicago a improv on the end of
Chicago yeah are you reading that book I
start I have it yeah
this is help legendary would you go to
chin all this comedy club in America um
The Improv Wow yeah yes the out against
Airlines in New York is the oldest
what's that couch Airlines second city
the snow that's a pop legend that's no
ii see he's been around a long time
because it was founded by yeah but tall
sales that's where i'm prime profit
started in chicago really come restore
1972 okay Caroline's his when eighties
eighties yeah well in 1980 we moved to
Times Square but I am done Caroline's
much gotham saw it was put a say Gotham
yeah it's also a lot of people lot of
times feel like I'm gonna do this a lot
of times it's my our agent has a
relationship with certain yeah and I do
too I'm friends with Christmas only who
I love and I got them yeah I love them
too but it's nothing against them and
how to go play it Carol I also have you
can see so many weekends
yeah or oh I'll go over the street to
the Gramercy Theatre yeah there has
nothing to do with that's right well
laughter and you booked up the comment
after a while you outgrow club they say
right see you have Tim just saying the
oldest chin no well how the [ __ ] is is
so hard to find you see her it all this
comedy clubs in the world you know
people are yelling at you over the I
know dude I know that's alright I don't
give a [ __ ] us a second city that's the
same bother you know it's just just the
bad way I would one of the five with
Manhattan
let me see that Brooklyn piped
solely good to us this forum yeah weird
bad how the [ __ ] that's so Todd's weird
it's downright weird it's very strange
but I was telling John I was driving
through Los Feliz
let's finish those fields fading in
Silver Creek it's nice up there master
there's huge beautiful houses it's
really nice or you can get a
mention up there it's really nice enjoy
that though when it's really hot and
also it's very convenient it's not
everywhere though it's it's it's where a
lot of people insist on living cuz I
know I was wondering why someone like
Marin Silverlight is silver logic people
I don't like it though
Schuyler I bought dubs house a long time
do you like it I bought Doug's house 10
years ago out there do you like it I
didn't why Echo Park it saw like I was
not there I always think the west sides
like you have to be here now that I'm
traveling more you know like the air is
different on the west side the the for
me for me I just but it's true it's sad
look look this is amazing
if you like that if you like a big house
you can get an amazing how the hip
there's a hipster vibe down the hall
read-only restaurants yeah I like to be
able to walk I don't like having more
eyes everywhere yes sort of sort of
certain areas hmm I just think Los
Angeles at the end of the day is ugly
and I and that all of it and I think the
sea the ocean makes it bearable even if
I can't see the ocean knowing it's close
to me no see I don't think la is ugly I
love LA I hate it you're talking loudly
yeah to me see I think New York sorry
people New York is hard to live in it's
like a lot of work you know but New York
is got such yes or you go I can walk in
to see his clothes New York allows me to
walk everywhere and I think that's the
difference like downtown New York I can
stroll I can get anywhere between
buildings non-stop yeah there's a herd
of course I like driving you can't drive
in New York yeah [ __ ] car now if you
live in Jersey I don't like driving your
drive or or you take a fight or you
become a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
take the subway everywhere yeah that's
[ __ ] miserable I'm just not that guy
I understand it is tough it's a lot of
noise it's it's so weird and I just
bought a [ __ ] house and I'm like dude
I could live there's a bunch of places I
could live for me it's just cuz of y'all
wanna be close to the Stewart stuff like
that but then I look at the hours it's
like I could manage to make it work I
just have to leave my house earlier you
wouldn't want to do that that's a lot
trust me trust me it's it's it's a TI
I'm looking to trade off because it's
like right well don't you arrive a nice
big house here but you get so much more
land everything here and then you're
just waking up really driving more I
know I'm supposed to be like we all say
so there's a reason there's a reason as
a guy who's lived everywhere in Los
Angeles flat lands are Hollywood but
you're not a homebody like me but I
still lived everywhere in Los Angeles
there's a reason that property is so
much more expensive down the Westside oh
but do you ride the beach everything's
down this this is the popular area it's
also what I quote the popular area that
I mean everyone wants to be here there's
a reason for it the beach
it's a popular really cool rest but can
I also say another thing and it may not
seem like a thing there are two things
going on
one is that it's and literally 20 to 25
degrees cooler down here throughout the
day than it is up there and more
importantly because of the way the wind
blows the smog heard this motion is
right it's pushed against those mountain
yeah so you're always in that haze and I
promise you again if somebody spent 23
years here that gets to you that wears
on you but some people don't mind it and
the air is getting cleaner yeah I know
and and I'm not saying that lust Feliz
and Silver Lake aren't awesome because
there's a lot about them I don't do that
I've never really been through I was
like hold up it's like and dude a year
ago six months ago if you want to argue
on me how it's better to live in Las
Venus or silver lake or Sherman Oaks or
anywhere Thousand Oaks
I would have [ __ ] dissed you get a
hell of a place now I was like dude you
can get a hell of a school oh yeah I
mean be careful you'll depress yourself
because you can get some beautiful spots
there and I got a great house here but
I'm just like man that the rat-race were
in I think it's because I'm like seeing
more and more like more of America with
through stand-up like I'm traveling so
much
I see like these big-ass yards I know
open fields I'm right now I don't know
if this is the place to raise my kid may
have to Tampa was a place to raise my
kid oh I think about it all the time
brother I think about it all that I
would eat like you want to go you have a
good-size yard I'm like nope where I
grew up not concerned [ __ ] you got a
tampa and you can have giant acacia
trees but then you can't live like I
can't do my job in living time
I couldn't do any of my good go see I
have to be in LA I have to obviously the
economy store or Laugh Factory and I
have to be here to work on my craft and
stand up and you and me but you know you
I could live in I could live anywhere
around the area and still make it happen
yeah because we don't have 9:00 to 5:00
that's the other thing it's true but if
you have a meeting at 3:00 or 4:00 and
you don't get the [ __ ] out by then
you're searing some big two hours yeah
but again I'm a whole body you know I'm
saying for now until you can't be
anymore you know I'm doing I'm busy as
[ __ ] at nights you know I won't work
in the comedy club but there's not
traffic then that's true
all right so I don't know I think I've
been on swift kick I came back from
Oklahoma and I get it when I can
Francisco and they took me was expensive
as hell but yeah that's whatever but no
but the thing is is when you go outside
of there like Monterey and you know and
like those cities I'm like hold up here
because sir I live in Big Sur Oh or went
out like La Jolla are you [ __ ] me
[ __ ] what are we doing I'm in this
[ __ ] bra now that I've been doing it
for 23 years I've been in traffic
forever I but we have to do it we have
to do it and it doesn't make it easy I
can't say that out loud but but there's
no reason why so many people celebrities
live in Calabasas and all that then go
all gonna walk there and then come here
they got away there's a reason for it
yeah that's right and there can they
keep moving it is Ellen Ellen Oprah live
in Ojai
yep yep that's that's good good gorgeous
oh hi skew don't feel like you're you
have you ever been up there chin it's I
mean you're in the middle of the [ __ ]
no one it's a mountain to tales of ocean
it's [ __ ] great and and then there
you're right there are so many places in
this country that are just like you can
fourth for really California man it's
like but in Texas like allows a tax on
my do like how I got to Austin dude like
my boy Matt best who just bought a place
in in heute and yes Utah no no they left
Utah there and Oh San Antonio yeah and I
was a he's tell me all the land they
bought and I was like how much you pay a
Mike dude I'm gonna buy San Antonio
no sweetie - I'm gonna purchase
anhedonia now I know it did it's my -
great my favorite thing is to go look at
property that's where I go every one I
think about what I paid here and then I
look at property and I go home there's
just so many great places to live but I
have a fantasy of selling my house and
just going so if you have to be here
look up look up property in Boise Idaho
which I hear great things about it's
another example mmm can't do snow any
worse no California I'm all game Texas
game yeah now you lost me a boo-boo easy
breath I just hear that you busted up
every good conversation some nice time I
don't know what we do buddy this is what
we do for now snow you know as far as
[ __ ] Woodland Hills well he lives way
out there but he's he's got he's
podcasting goes back you know yeah Joe
likes to be on top of the hill with lots
of guns and lots of dogs ready for
whatever comes and his bow and arrow you
get into his house you're gonna take an
arrow right to the [ __ ] I don't know
I've been on this word kick lately I I
went running down Venice the other day I
went from marina Santa Monica really and
dude there are so many bums out bums god
I saw a bum fight with two bikes you did
yes fascinating there by each other like
like [ __ ] like a javelin with two
bikes you don't say I know it's very
strange Jesus I think they were feeding
him so they were all gathered in one
area and I guys Bible is by the by the
[ __ ] trail
yeah and I was like when the [ __ ] like a
Gracie grew up invest in the summers
like I've never seen it so bad man but
they're like give him food or something
they're all just fighting for it as
strange vibes and then I left my car
right off Main Street and it looked like
there was a ticket on my car Mike
[ __ ]
then I get it in this this guy who owns
the some ice cream shop where the only
guys who come out of coconut milk big
fan whatever I get left a gift
certificate I'm like I just burned about
2,000 calories because I did boxing
before this when I'm about six mile run
I could have a little sweet you know
I've earned it yeah [ __ ] earned
you've earned it why go in there
and didn't feel like it but they had
this coconut milk mmm my mouth is
watering from a now it was ice cold milk
Thai coconut milk it is like a cream
they had some sort of cloaking it had a
little meat and it dude sometimes you
can puree the meat throw that that [ __ ]
was so [ __ ] refresh it's very
refreshing my word yeah my leg yeah well
they don't do that in in certain parts
you could somebody will get coconut and
just they'll have a bunch of coconuts
and ice and he's dragging it along the
beach then just take him my chat down
chop the top off throw a strong there
you'll sip it no you know what mom my
momma bird would do when I was a kid cuz
I was a weird kid so - pipe me down cuz
I was singing and dance and doing random
[ __ ] well what they would do is buy me a
coconut from King Soopers and then give
me a butter and I forgot their get it
open and I was occupied for hours that's
amazing yeah took hours to get out but I
do you know what my mom I'm gonna get it
done and I would suck all the meat out
you know my mother used to do to me for
real stupid faith no you know sheís do
to me when I was being a nuisance in a
department store locked her out of it I
swear to god she'd go she'd go I just
saw a lady with the biggest minis I've
ever seen semi titties yep and I go
where and I go looking for and I go I
don't see her and that's how she would
keep me thank you so much I was I was
taking the laws in the tits as a boy mom
how more than asses and and and and not
huge personalities you're in acid I just
like an athletic woman and if she
doesn't have big tits but a crazy ass
and like oh man I mean yeah yeah but I
said you know what to choose these days
you know you don't have to ask them to
bowl for 300 out yeah yeah like all all
the above yeah that's very strange swing
your mom kept you occupied cuz I figured
she'd go there's a man around the store
with a blonde ass and a fat dick go find
him for me he's got a serious bulge and
a blowout ass listen I did what I
thought yes but you started all beard
and a full I saw a full grown man
probably father of seven with a fat [ __ ]
hanging on the front of his khakis it's
really you can't find him like this is
like Where's Waldo its pop tetanus
and he's got a blowout ass with very
strong cross now go find him Brian oh
it's a full beard and slicked back go
find him while me your father do some
shopping and full sleeve tattoos yeah
finish change it is very strange
but the point is I want to move out I
know I know I don't know what it is
would you live so would it be Texas no I
don't count my heart's in California
hard to argue with Santa Barbara oh hi
Brentwood
you live in Brentwood the Hills the
Brentwood with that trails that it's not
though that's with you and those hills
band there's some land you have to have
some cash but there's some lands gonna
have all the cash oh yeah got to have
all the cash your neighborhood is your
neighbors come harvest Wars narrow and
Steven Spielberg's giving hearts oh yeah
yeah didn't your kid grows up to be a
little [ __ ] though I don't know you
just don't just that's a problem
honestly
oh my kitchen how about we sign my son
up for soccer
well what these other two year-olds
don't realize is Papa gots bills and my
kid's gonna have playing Premier League
so we've been playing soccer since about
eight months old now and he dribble and
kicked the [ __ ] out of a soccer ball
yeah so when he plays with other
two-year-olds and he looks like a giant
Messi like you know what this probably
isn't the league for him so let's find
him another league is that true yeah you
went on Saturday and they're like like
they're these tiny balls Mike
we didn't he's not [ __ ] three months
old give us a pretty you play with a
regular soccer ball you know I'm sorry
I'm gonna be playing soccer
nah not for this kid now now have you
been watching any of the FIFA buy any do
you mean all of it in trucking let's
bring it home you [ __ ] about anything
in Sweden how about Croatia against
Russia for Croatia
what pressure I'd love to go crazy I
heard it's gorgeous who has more
pressure on the goalie or the guy
kicking the goal the guy kicking the
goal the goalies not expected to stop
angry you know that there's no pressure
on the girl like yeah if he if he misses
a goal people like yeah no [ __ ] it's
impossible to stop yeah dude I hope it's
Belgium first England [ __ ] France
[ __ ] Croatia yeah I'm English so
faker and throat so in the future you
play Minot kind of cro cop over and over
to
the troops it feels like and it feels
like they truly have they could win this
all I mean it's gonna be tough to beat
[ __ ] Oh Croatia they can do it for
sure
oh Christ I considered a better team uh
I I wanted I want rush to went to the
rushes not that good yeah I want a rush
to win - because I'm in Russia [ __ ] do
you think they're doing all the cheating
you know what no one thinks it's a
little suspect that they've never had a
good team and all of a sudden it's in
their homeland and they go really far
what do you what do you think is going
on they're the best of cheating they've
always been the best achievement what
are they doing see never seen a Kuras
are they drugged but that doesn't make
you a better sock does it well I'm sure
I am I to play at that level you've got
to be such a ridiculously good athlete
what do you place that [ __ ] when you
place them as athletes top top top would
you buy me all of them anyone doing
professional sports are [ __ ] easy
did you see Travis personís speaking
Travis Prasanna right strong first Ron
did you see him mimicking Evel Knievel
doing the jump I was [ __ ] live last
night I watch it live it drives persona
jumpin Caesars Palace let me say this
it's a it was a three-hour live long
broadcast our boy Sal held it down yeah
Johnny Knoxville on there who Johnny had
so much makeup and Dittus here it looks
very awkward and Johnny Rock field
looked so [ __ ] bored you look so
bored I was mine now the thing is when
you watch Evel Knievel do it on the old
school bike back then didn't have the
same technology it's impressive when you
wait three hours and watch Travis do it
I'm sure it's very tough I'm sure I
definitely can't do it but it's very
very underwhelming let me see it watch
it
now imagine you're waiting an hour for
this Brian okay you're the hot 120
jumping a ramp the Caesars first jump
buses then he jumps the Caesar Palace
fountains go ahead watches
[Music]
look at the crowd all the other ones are
shortened this by the way let me see
this again mmm I wait an hour for this
one thousand two one thousand three one
thousand no harder this is the first job
now now take off the fireworks and
imagine that if I were to make the
coolest now I love Travis I don't this
Caesar his palace fountain he does yeah
which is parties everywhere stood now no
he first though the Caesar Palace
fountains tougher because it's such a
short ramp oh these were people yo 70
then he jumps the buses let me say I'm
gonna watch these most kids are there
yeah I agree old-school vintage I'm
surely very hard well I do wake behind a
fox right oh yeah but this is easy for a
guy like Tim but I know what you mean
like it's very very straightforward
right but when you watch these guys you
know what that's him those guys here's
all the records oh he's the best of all
time no but the guys who do the back
flips him oh okay so he's the best of
all time doing that so do you see him do
big air they seem do this all the way so
big air is why what yeah they seem to
get higher with big elf yeah but that
you remembered like they're trying to
mimic the this bike Oh what's this this
scares the [ __ ] this is where he's jump
in the well that scares the [ __ ] out of
me though dude ready but again now I
waited three hours for this Brian now
the Vintage Leather shooting and the
bike is sick
see there's no room to gate gain speed
if you yeah if you don't get it right
most people don't lie on that though I
guess because you can't enough time to
stop that's hard a lot of time yeah yeah
oh that's not but yeah it makes me
nervous but I know you mean he's such a
batter saying is it you're impressed
it's awesome I love care I love drugs
yeah but when I watch right yeah I've
seen you do more dangerous stuff on boy
yeah
the funniest was watching Johnny
Knoxville face he looked bored to tears
in the bath Johnny not just time self to
a Rockettes and Johnny Knoxville's nuts
and then they brought in force Griffin
they said random people and they'll
force what's going through his mind in
force goes I know nothing about
motorcycles however in fighting this
would be the third round so he's been
through it a few times I love forest
birds me a [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] about
motorcycles go yeah force is great
[ __ ] hilarious
I love force I did go to eBook to Neils
jump but see back then they have all the
cool [ __ ] yeah I never missed a take-off
landings but that motorcycle is not
great that's another one that he jumped
and he isn't a toughest competitor in
the world he beat you
coming back for any Late Show that's two
but vivo feels confident Knievel was
supposed to be like I talked to George
Hamilton about him
George Hamilton said he first town is
his famous movie stars bad guy held a
gun to my head and Evel Knievel you know
Evel Knievel right bank robber also
geneva bank robber no hold on watch your
[ __ ] mouth
Bank right around the July 4th solar I
called you the [ __ ] big gay eagle now
you're going bad an evil bank robber and
also also a reporter wrote an
unflattering article about him well he
showed up with a baseball bat and put
that guy in the hospital broke his legs
and arm rightfully so yeah what do you
write about him he said some [ __ ]
about him and I was like Evel Knievel
was like really on the fan you don't
take a future that's awesome no he was
at girls 8 he was a rough dude who
robbed banging that up chin is this true
now it's in his auto is in his biography
they did I saw a thing on you would [ __ ]
dudes up and he didn't apologize he goes
he wrote something bad about me and I I
decided that that was the last time he's
gonna write something bad about somebody
and I mean at least he showed up you
googled evil report what [ __ ] it gen
look evil Knievel read yeah there you go
I just put it up first to see what stop
so that that one time evil Knievel be
Sonia with a baseball bat fact yeah
patience he was a badass man talks about
that doesn't mean he's a bad guy though
what just means he's muster man for
years so someone accused of him being
violent and man I've super skeptical I
know he admits it admits but look at
this one scroll up chin leave it leave
it up top he goes Evel Knievel once flew
to California just to beat the crap out
of a person who'd accused him of being
violent and abusive with a baseball bat
this is particularly notable because
Knievel had two broken arms at the time
and both of them were still in cast well
it says now no charges were ever filed
against Knievel documents released by
the FBI after his death revealed that he
was linked to no less than a half dozen
serious assaults that led to people
being
hospitalized the only reason they
couldn't pin anything on him is because
the assaults were conducted by people
believed to be acting on behalf of
Knievel and none of them ever admitted
to it if you're thinking that this all
sounds a little too far-fetched we
should point out that almost all the
assaults the FBI investigated were
against rival stuntmen and promoters
many of whom Knievel had threatened hell
in one case the guy had the [ __ ] kicked
out of him just hours after receiving a
threatening phone call from Knievel
personally however it is unable to press
any charges because the only thing he
saw of his attacker was his shoes as
they kicked him in the neck and head
yeah he was a rough dude he was not a
good guy but he was a ballsy guy yeah
but he did he was linked to some bank
robbers robberies he started robbing
banks well what when he was younger he's
the kind of guy that was just so he got
a scam is gutsy he just be like I'll
[ __ ] go let's go rob a bank you could
anybody like that who needs all Cowboys
but but Travis is the same even more so
Travis jumps out of those didn't those
squirrels suit Travis's all that he's
not robbing banks is it good well that's
so there's that personality type that's
fearless that day they have and some of
them can be have anti-social behavior to
their aggressive mm-hmm anyway don't
ever go bad on the old Knievel bro he's
an American treasure buddy big gamer
girl striking again speaking of American
treasures can we talk a little bit about
Daniel Cormier I know it who now again
I've said it from from day one is to me
the most impressive fighter the most
impressive fighter to ever step in the
Octagon for what he's able to do and now
he beat his house more than John Jones
yes more than John Jones and I'll tell
Anna I'll tie like that for an hour
right on the edge and I'll tell you why
but here's why I got Daniel Cormier
number one if you look at his stature if
you look at what he's he's working with
he is not what you would consider a
specimen he's not he's not six four he's
not dealing with long reach he's not
dealing with all that stuff but his
ability to put you on your back to find
a way to win to break you down whatever
it might be
and then here he comes and takes steep
Amy Osuch who's starched every
heavyweight
he's coming up across except for Junior
dos Santos know a lot of you haven't
strew your answer but but steep Amy
osich who who has defended his title I
think more successfully than almost
anybody else right okay more though
anyone needs a big deal and then Daniel
knocks him out in the first round at all
and I just all I can say is and he's
such a class act now here's the
asterisks with John Jones do I think
John Jones is in many ways the best
fighter to ever step in the Octagon
talent-wise
I do has he beaten Daniel Cormier
decisively twice yes is he a better
fighter if you look at those two fights
you have to say yes a couple asterixis
one we can talk about peds that has to
factor it the conversation would be huge
it has to factor in the conversation I
don't know to what degree but also I
feel like John how many fights his John
had how many fights his DC had DC's
never lost but to John Jones and
sometimes by the way you could also say
styles make fights and John Jones has
his number right or now that doesn't
work does it Sean that does that hurt
sure let me ask you this so I'm on board
with you let me ask you seize the goat
okay that doesn't work when does John
senses nervous John do that but here's a
better question I know I mean my math is
tricky but does John do that too steep a
meiosis they both beat him he knocks him
out like that I think he beats him I
don't we've never seen John at
heavyweight as DC at light heavyweight
is in uh knocked out DC with that I've
seen John fight somebody his length
those in Alexander Gusterson and it was
tough so he did three weeks a training
kit okay but but to see him fight DC has
never been a knockout artist ever ever
he just grinds you down you know he
knocked out Antonio Bigfoot Silva other
than that he's really you know so you
have you FDCs goat well I have DCs go
because if we're gonna do go you can't
with with greatest of all time you can't
test positive
or any performance-enhancing drugs as
soon as you test I'll give you if you
test once all right all right may it
happens you sound super strict I'll
still let you in my lane okay you test
twice
yeah there's obviously something fishy
going on you're out so interesting
silver and John Jones are out so who's
left George st. Pierre Mighty Mouse in
DC so are you gonna stream those three
and I gave DC the nod there mmm I did
too I have to but if John you know there
weren't its name in argument if John
doesn't test positive for those stuff
you know John you gotta give it to John
100% but when you test positive for peds
and coke you're out what like social
dancing like Muhammad Ali also also the
only time we've ever seen John clean
that we know for a fact was against OSP
he looked like [ __ ] in that fight yeah
so can I so let me ask you this so I
think DC heavy do you want to see that
that's the fight that's the biggest says
John does John come up and do that oh
for sure John wants that yeah hell yeah
John wants that his DC's doing
everything that John wanted to do he's
living John's live DC beats John yeah
that's true if DC beats child
heavyweight I mean it's his last fight
no matter what the problem with DC is
you know they wanna do that brock lesnar
if I brought can't fight til next year
he's out to make sure why cuz there's
suspension and you saw the pool stuff so
he's out to next year I don't want you
see say he's retiring in March I don't
want to see Brock fight Sablin
you know I mean saddening alright it's
gonna happen I was happy for DC though
meant yeah if you're a DC fan you want
to see a fight Brock you want to you
make money and that's the easiest fight
you can have right now that's real money
yeah you know you fight your entire life
to get to that point so are you [ __ ]
impressive
III said I just antigen wrong times no
skins I've said that to Daniel 3 2 pitch
in your leg for about 2 minutes now how
are you talking about let me see you bro
no come on let me show it to the beat
come on dummy where it's bad dude
yeah I mean that's big oh yeah oh you
have some new camouflage jeans my skin
oh now that looks like it's been that
it's been rubbed raw in that area dude
yeah it's an issue why you get better
you you need to it's [ __ ] doctors I
have talked to shrug and give you creams
we'll use the cream yeah I gotta use the
cream I ran out yeah it's a tricky thing
man yeah it's bad but we'll figure it
out it's there to figure out it's there
to defeat and I like the idea it's been
weird psoriasis because it forced me to
eat differently so I feel really good
but my skin sucks and also I don't go
back to what you were eating just take
pills bro yeah well I could take Humera
but that take a look at those side
effects huh that's a wonder drug it'll
stop it in his tracks but man I'm gonna
figure it out that's weird you didn't
miss it since since I've ever seen since
it when I was turned 51 it's never gone
away it just got bad and it just it's
just I got sick hey whatever got your
honor and I never want to ever diet
you're on stop doing it yeah it's the
worst I've ever seen brother yeah I know
why don't you just try that carnival for
like a couple weeks it's just not
sustainable but I am what if I'm doing a
variation of I'm being very strict I
just stepped off of it like an [ __ ]
when I step off that's the problem
so mmm just what I'm dealing with that's
my thing that's right
hey bro psoriasis is my thing you know
some people's things are I don't know
football basketball my red skins mine
remember red spotted left for him I'm
the old spotty would he get his box
Oh call me spots twice you said LeBron
jerseys were out of stock so it looks
like there's 600 percent higher
pre-orders for those when he goes to LA
the [ __ ] Lakers but pin before when
he returned to the Cavs when he went
back home yeah this is the biggest
server so I'll say in Spanish the Lakers
the Brahmas shave his beard
don't like it on him I don't think it
looks good darris oh no that one that's
too long there he shaved it since then
yeah that's not current one yeah it
looks a lot weird there
the pit that you see the big mural they
did some art [ __ ] it up but then the
artists fix it this morning
only did yeah they fix it thick why they
[ __ ] it up they like wrote all over it
not not our king like all right [ __ ]
more that was the next one on the plane
started talking to the guy in front of
me he goes well right now we lost about
three we lost about twelve players so
but where we're looking at when a draft
it what it looks like and he was just so
into it I was like man you you really
identify with your team he's the guy fix
that
how sick is that looking though that
mural is sick three and six you
referring to three and six and finals
shut up I know it looks like the game
how about who is that though that murals
[ __ ] sake okay hold up that's that
guy's thinking only has seven and thirty
puff lights that's the graph that's the
Granado
it's a fun dense thick got fifty
definitely give me a Lakers Jersey
though I don't want yellow doc you don't
wear bright yellow or should I become a
a Lakers fan if you want man I think I
need to worry about you psoriasis first
and foremost yeah I wouldn't do anything
else just put all my energy on you why
cuz I'm doing a TV show where after
where Schwartz mm-hmm
should be interesting yeah I'm sure when
they cover it with makeup that it's a
helping off to get in an hour early
that's good at least I got to solve it
before then you have to all yes right
yeah few weeks what else all right this
is in the news and people were making a
big deal out of it that Anthony Bourdain
was apparently worth 1.2 million dollars
but they're saying that there could be a
lot of hidden things like my friend said
you could have a trust that no one knows
I'm sure he could have a bunch of stuff
but this is what it was like you know
the sound public that he was worth to
1.2 million and he's leaving the
majority of it to his daughter
um I bet his house is worth more than
that yeah that's really that's not a lot
of money
doesn't make sense
he had a major hit show don't accept
that he'd make that off just a show
alone he'd make that a month the I heard
also heard that he had a bunch of
investments that some didn't work out
like he either must been had a horrible
gambling a drinking problem where all
his money went or he just made a
horrible investments if that's all he
has left after all the [ __ ] he's done
the book that's crazy chef oh yeah
that's he'd make this appearance fees
he'd make two times that much just hold
on we saw reports of 16 million dollar
forge according to the legal dice which
were first word by page six borns assets
include four and twenty five thousand
cash in savings thirty five thousand a
brokerage account two unfitting personal
and five or thousand tangible property
including royalties and residuals that's
not what I'm talkin fused yeah
what was he spend his money on or it
could be what bad friend said trust like
just money that that's not public yeah
he'd leave to his daughter boy but it
makes him look bad though so bad for his
daughter she's eleven I have a
ten-year-old hmm it can't it doesn't
make sense at all so that it's got to be
somewhere
none of it makes sense how about that
yeah that's his daughter
no if you mean if you type in how much
Anthony burning got paid to do his show
it'd be way more than that and how many
seasons was it on row 11 and he was a
producer of it it makes no sense he was
making that a month is a huge making
that a month I can tell you was not
always spent with his money
[Music]
oh well well any deed go through divorce
no until he's 44 yeah what you saying he
did want to start saying Scout to use 44
he wasn't smart with his money until he
was yeah so that's it didn't save didn't
have a savings account sell 44 so he
could just be really bad with money and
there's a lot of people like that yeah
yeah I don't know FL guys that live
paycheck to paycheck they can't wait for
the monies paychecks for the gate
because they spent all of it every week
that is it's fun while you're doing it
though
Tom oh hi so he's talked to us financial
struggles and stuff interesting before
when he was doing drugs oh well yeah
yeah drug problem yeah that's very
interesting though what else you get
this one lions killed three poachers who
are trying to kill rhinos for their
horns and they actually ate them and
toured the bodies to shreds
they found like shoes read it and
another body part no this is this
happened before - oh it's happened again
now where Lions killed poachers or
animals killed poachers yeah poachers
again I'm sure this happens more often
we found enough body parts in three
periods of empty shoes which is justice
that the lines at least three of them
but thick bush there could be more they
found silencers axes they came into the
hole to poach all poaching kit the six
lines have to be tranquilized for the
human remains to be recovered that's
always stupid to me I know once they
taste human blood without nature and he
went into the [ __ ] area and then you
we kill them it's so strange but then
they do become human honk our stomachs
because they like our sweet fatty blood
you know what don't go hunting rhinos at
night in Lion Country they do in Africa
enough it could be such a hard path for
the Sierra Nevada yeah another one so
this is a really sad story of a polar
bear polar bear who killed a man that
was protecting his two kids
polar bears are the meanest he's 31 yeah
Papa fishing hunting claws on the
windows foot is where well South are
shot a movie a realtor said he died a
hero tones Dodger run while he put
himself between the them and the bear
yeah that's pretty gangster and he did
have a gun on him but not when this
happened so one of the Bears is actually
going stalking one of the kids so he ran
towards it and didn't have a gun on him
at that time he was enjoying his day
with his children and then they were
surprised by a bear that had
- stalker charge towards one of his
children Wow
when she heard the call for help it was
terrible to listen - [ __ ] that's
terrible so people are saying how sad
this is but then you know especially
because there are little kids but
they'll always remember their dad is
someone who did that for them what do
you think I thought there was gonna be
another death getting eaten alive but I
mean sacrificing himself yeah maybe I
don't know how that works
that's so a primordial you're gonna do
whatever you can of true kid but also
let's not bring up let's not bring our
kids around where there's polar bears
well I'll have a gun nope so it said hey
Brendan why you live in Nunavut you
don't have a choice they're up in the
Arctic so when when will was there he
was talking to this Arctic gal this this
this Inuit girl and she was like Inuit
and a mix of Inuit and Dutch her
something she was really pretty and he
goes how you doing she was great now I
was hungry and she's reaching in and
eating pieces of raw caribou yeah that's
their life yes that's what they grew up
in and the polar bears - with 380 polar
bear sightings in Hammond - under 17
predominately Inuit Kamini has become
increasingly concerned for the public
safety the number of polar bears in
western Hudson Bay region remains stable
at around 840 yeah I mean if that's how
you know of course you can take your
kids down there I mean polar bears but
definitely have a gun with you yeah he
just didn't have it on him he had it
with them but not on they are rare the
last death was in 2000 yeah you don't
see polar bears are the meanest ones
this guy's - this guy who got attacked
in his tent up there somewhere and the
polar bear attacked him and crawled
through the tent grabbed him by the head
pulled him out of a sleeping bag and his
buddy goes Fogg ah he's getting pulled
out he's getting he said and ripped
pulled out by his head and his friend
pulls out a shotgun it goes good news
good news and shoots the [ __ ] polar
bear polar bear dies his friends like
guys had he scalped and he's all bunched
up and all night they had to sit there
and they said they built a fire and they
had and he had to sit awake
cuz you can't go to sleep because now
that you killed the whole er bear
other bears smell it and they come in so
now you got to sit there can't you drag
that [ __ ] bear somewhere he well
they're about 1,300 pounds but go ahead
and no no you can't you can't drag it
anywhere and you won't because there's
other camps and move somewhere else sure
can't because it's dense dark and it
sucks well sit there by the fire and
when we outs the butts
sleeping and you know you know you're
you know you find out if a polar bears
creeping up because you don't hear it
no you don't hear it you hear the what
do you hear on your back what are you
here how do you know a polar bears
coming up you assume you have dogs they
better have your dogs and how many and
there's only a couple kind of dogs that
can survive that they the other dogs die
of the cold your German Shepherd ain't
making you the husky no Huskies can't
handle it either there's a type of dog
sled dog that'll take its nose put it
right in its crotch curl up on the ice
and go to sleep
that's how they that's how you can't do
it nope too cold in certain parts
Siberian and even a Malamute apparently
will die but there's another sled dogs
those dogs can do it Samoyed no
greenland Chinook no I mean those
Alaskan you know but there there's a dog
that a sled dog that'll actually do it
and my buddy Sam Sheridan who lived with
the Inuit was telling me about it
there's one dog your buddy's saying was
lying because it says Siberian Huskies
are bred for it well did the ones who
see the ones that you see are not the
ones yeah pretty sure so Bunyan Huskies
were made for it bro boy Sam's lying
there's one dog cuz I've been sled I've
been on sleds I asked him what kind of
dogs do and they told me there's one
beyond survives it whoa huh when it
plunged to minus 130 in 1973 the
Iditarod mushers complained not the dogs
oh and those were than three the males
can handle serious hey hey so it says
the only dogs that can deal with this
cold are ready
Siberian Hoss
geez Alaskan Malamutes and then some
other one I can't pronounce yes a mix of
a husky type dog
well Francine was lying to you it's a
mix yeah you don't know that does like
you were saying I can't figure it out
who's all full of [ __ ]
well well Sam I'm definitely not so both
were 3,000 but whatever the case the
size matters he's lost in this service
the body them the more surface of an
animal has that more heated losses yeah
move on wait wait I'm going to talk
about was I you reminded me of something
about cold oh you know what Heather
animal can handle major temperature
drops penguins not bad - geese certain
like certain like like birds can handle
the coldest coldest temperature yeah
penguin bro then goes south they can fly
south then they go way north they can be
on the Arctic you're like freezing and
I'm in a goosal land and be like hey
what's up everybody I have a [ __ ] you
warm goose well because they're their
feathers keep a warm layer of air around
their body okay make sure you use
crystal for any of the listeners we have
left I want you to know Brian I care
about cold weather and we care about no
we don't know we're gonna hold weather
animals so we know penguins are very
good at leopard seal suggestion this one
were Matt Serra subdued some drunk guy
is cracking out he's right before the
Hall of Fame induction so what happened
exactly
guy was like according to Matt the guy
was just like like harassing waitresses
and waiters and people in there and then
he also took a swing at that Sara that's
what Matt Sara says what's the video
this is Matt Serra subduing him but the
way he says it is funny the way Matt
talks
as I calm down calm down the guys
charlie cuz Matt doesn't know what he's
doing from Maui gets a regular dude and
he's smiling everyone's cheering him on
why's it get shirt over his face good
the guys are so drunk lazy his
girlfriend was passed out by the way
those are the security officers coming
up control em you want you some help
super calm and now I getting out
security guards in shape to handle the
situation they just feel like you Mac
you should get him out of here for us
yeah Matt conscious but it was asleep
between dragged him out here that's
great now we're all the security guards
Oh Beast she wouldn't play this this is
before it happened so that's the guy
trying to wake up his grow
let me say I love that sir
oh no she it's like it's like weekend at
birdie
[Laughter]
she's so out of it well Bernie's the
guy's [ __ ] be mean to waitresses and
[ __ ] that's what he says I'm sure Matt
Matt Matt's not that dude he's not like
for it to know I mean I'm sure with Matt
like saying this stuff the guy probably
heard him talking is like I don't think
so he's so drunk punches and some people
yeah yeah Matt just he definitely want
to just do that to do it
did you see the the [ __ ] the I think
you freaked Mississippi or something
like that where this guy whose food was
staying too long come in so he punches
the waitress now this is what the [ __ ]
you doing yeah let's watch this and they
they actually know who this guy is
the go home are you PC and then boom
thank goodness you had that Socrates
I'll pull you but you wish she really do
this then the guy gets shot in the face
you know I don't think you should die
just in the guts out [ __ ] hurt look
at this piece of [ __ ] man you piece of
[ __ ] you just hit that woman in the face
because your food was taking too long oh
[ __ ] that's that makes me so angry
hopefully the people see that guy he
loses his job and all that [ __ ] he needs
to lose his job for sure I used I have a
feeling it's gonna get way worse now
that's that's big-time assault good luck
getting anybody to hire you you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] let us get
gender I got a bunch of stuff here let's
see it well D I don't know much about
basketball
but this guy who was supposed to be a
star college student star college player
and great in the NBA and the Weiner in
the NBA he was in the Sacramento Kings
he made it for a little while
yeah yeah and then played like China
Russia Russia yes so I thought you knew
him but I heard he was at UCLA but 20
hullick died of self-inflicted gunshot
wound
yeah so he was he a standoff was it in
where was that Sherman Oaks
Los Angeles yeah Sherman Oaks and then
what exactly tipped him off like what
happened his used a stud in high school
yeah
his coach I guess he still has a
relationship with his college coach and
the coach said that he was going
some rough times especially you know
kind of being lonely in a different
country when he's playing over there
okay and then what he get he would get
random text messages that made him think
like this guy's something's gonna happen
so he called his mom and the moms like
no he has a gun now and he's he seems
like he's going crazy cuz he wanted to
go there and talk to him first but he
was know at this point you should call
the police
call 9-1-1 and then I guess there's a
standoff and there was a firing like he
shot fired at cop yeah so and the cops
fired back at him but it wasn't the
bullets from the cops he just killed
himself
man you know struggling some serious
depression
26 years old my next six man damn my
parents have an apartment in New York
City and I wrote a story about the
next-door neighbor she was always kind
of a loopy broad and these giant giant
firemen there are this kind of big
mustache and he they knocked in the door
and she goes hello he goes how you doing
I was right there and she goes I'm okay
and he goes were you sitting outside on
your on your air conditioner and she was
of 16:40 she goes she goes um I was yeah
and he goes do you think that's normal
and she goes uh yeah I was just do you
think that's you think that New York
fireman because you think that that was
normal to be sitting on top of your your
organism 16 floors up she goes yeah I
don't know what this isn't he goes
through her she goes oh she just
collapses and he grabbed her and there
she was obviously yeah and they saved
her life I mean you know god bless those
guys but it was such a it was robbing
and she she moved out of that apartment
yeah but my parents scooped it up type
move by the parents yeah I just never
feel so bad associations in a crisis
yeah but these giant men these giant men
in all their gear like they're built
like you just when you're a little woman
or even a man I mean they're just at
your door like that you you have no
chance oh just take me she's they just
scooped her up
giant heroes these giant saviors this is
such a shame though
it sucks it's a tragedy
I don't know there's a couple of racial
ones did you guys hear about that guy
who stops a black woman and her kid from
like he wanted to make sure that she
showed her her ID that she lives in the
area and maybe otherwise she can't be in
the pool but she had a key card to get
in I haven't heard about this so that
happened is it this one here almost
there
right here so this guy he was just being
a douche bag and and was asking this the
only black cop that was there know the
guy this guy holding this like sprinkler
whatever who the [ __ ] is he like the
community pool security or some [ __ ] he
just hangs out at the pool I guess he is
party so he has another job doing
something else but he was fired from
that but he did do he did do this like
reporting for the pool so what did he do
exactly a black lady was there in the
pool and he wanted to see her
credentials she needed to see her ID he
demanded ID otherwise she can't get into
the pool even though she has a keycard
so then he called the cops on her the
cops came by and said if the keycard
should be enough you don't need an ID
and then she did say like I'll show you
my ID too but then she just recorded it
to make sure that this guy knows that
this is completely wrong to do so
anyways he's fired from his actual job
now hood there's a guy there's a woman
though in Portland who came into a
bakery after hours and videoed her and
they were like well we can't serve you
were closed you guys well this would
like to be a black woman and all those
clerks lost their jobs and they were all
like we did with the register was closed
were closed and they they still lost
their job it was the white woman saying
this what it feels like to be a black
woman now as a black well it was like
and she was at grad students that rad
student in like you know [ __ ] I don't
know sociology and she was doing an
experiment was it like divided over was
it like they're closed closed closed and
she walked in there like when we close
the register we're not you know we can't
if we can't serve you yeah she was like
what the [ __ ] it's like come on you got
you're getting your [ __ ] with this I
think that's the exception though this
most people suck that's him that's
embarrassed and at the end of the whole
thing when the car
came and said that she's fine she went
she's lasting the guy can you just say
sorry sorry he just walks away that's
the way just apologize anyway just a
dick just dicks I think a lot of I think
a lot of them are just dicks yeah yeah
people I come from Macomb losers yeah
people out there just want to say shitty
to be shitty to people well that's good
I here's another interesting one I
bought a pool Oh
white lady property manager for this
place call the cops on a black guy
because he was wearing socks so I agree
with ya I was gonna say can't walk out
of the black/white China I don't care
you cannot wear socks and you don't eat
you fire my pool socks there's like
other rules you can't wear hats and
whatever else in there and then other
people were wearing that so I got the
Sun so people were wearing other things
that you're not supposed to wear but
they picked on the black isle with where
this is all like we're all getting crazy
now Jesus criminy she didn't she didn't
actually go walk over and tell him she
can't he can't do it she just called the
cops without even telling them that not
to not to wear socks well that's not
cool don't call the cops
yeah Hawk it out first go ahead bro can
you know where's the Ox cuz apparently
this is what I go you can't wear your
hat or t-shirts either no by the way
don't be so strict and also but don't
worry don't worry your socks do
something about wearing socks they sued
hey also your dorky and also though it's
hey bro come here come on
don't worry sucks let me tell you why
because it's ridiculously dorky it
pisses off all the men and also girls
actually and also for whatever dumb
reason we have this stupid rule where
you can't wear that stuff I agree
but when you fire somebody that's a
[ __ ] in your ass Oscar sure the Poulet
bills I used to wear shirts you wear
shirts and pool I think it why fat kids
do that it just feels a little safer it
just does what t-shirt I know safer you
know what cuz I was super super fat when
I was a kid he's where shirt in the pool
tomorrow nice that's that trauma from
your childhood
oh you're free so on always wears a
t-shirt you could be in a sauna and you
wear a t-shirt
you're playing beach volleyball at show
yeah because you see the black shirt
makes sense the kids always wear white
ones and then it's like if I'm skiing
the pool I talked like it's like you
can't kick it fat kid kid kid kid hog
kid in a white shirt yeah well will
cause it fat teenager syndrome he has it
he has FTS which is also gives you rage
will also a big man and he's a very big
man was a big sport
no he's three thirty please don't be
don't say that take you can take seventy
pounds off that but he has been 400
pounds tell you he also lost 200 pounds
in one year so wow yeah I remember when
he looked really like like buff like
lean and buff but he's big you're kind
to well I remember this let's try
walking strong I don't want well you
know like well like your best I love big
well yeah don't ever get skinny ever the
best I wish you'd get fat chin I am fat
no you're not I'm chubby for sure no
well I don't so I gotta get so much
cooler I don't see it a chop on you look
a big chin big champ hey Jen Jen what's
up bro you start wearing a hat and eye
patch for no reason I got a dream about
you I had a dream now that I remember
god damnit dream that my wife was
watching you sing then my wife went does
he know he's got hair like that and I
went what she goes he is just fantastic
with that hair and I was like yourself
gots to you hit hey [ __ ] you're you're
lusting chin chin have you done any new
songs not I yet no I have I'm working on
stuff for the the YouTube channel though
but I'm waiting for some artist to
finish animating if that makes any sense
so I made music in my record addition to
it yeah I'm just gonna have an animation
to it the guy that did the Nick Swardson
stuff for you guys know the animation
and the plane oh yeah role-playing that
guy Oh sick yeah what else yet all right
so the tie key thing remember we talked
about this before we thought that
everything everything is fine because
they got to the kids and the coach and
everyone was alive and healthy so it's
way worse than we imagined they're still
in that cave but they got him out bro
they got eight uh yeah this morning I
thought to go you sure yeah five to go
there's been the update and I'm gonna
have to go in I'll double-check but but
the sad thing is at this former Navy
SEAL who was bringing oxygen tanks to
them to the kids he died on the way back
[ __ ] yeah he ran out oxygen they don't
know what happened but he lost
consciousness he didn't run on oxygen by
the way it's a five-hour it's a
five-hour swim slash dive through mud
water because and you said he was
putting oxygen tanks along the way so
how did they get the boys out how did he
get him out there one diver with one boy
I think that's how they're gone
that's the last best thing I heard and I
also heard that you on musk sent over
some of his engineers to figure out how
to pump the water out
people are getting annoyed with us why
cuz anything is like oh I'm gonna send
my guys out there and you talk to
experts like it doesn't work that way he
goes I'm gonna build a submarine get
those kids out okay well do you have a
demo of this submarine you're just gonna
put it under there do you know the
conditions so this is what I was reading
is people are starting getting a little
annoyed with them cause like I have the
answer for like well no it doesn't work
that we got this but we got this like we
know it doesn't work that way you can't
just build this little submarine that
you're talking about to go into those
conditions and you're gone so also do
you have a have you done one have you
made a demo of it do you know what's
gonna work can it guarantee the kids
safety like he has good intentions stop
the rain please like though he just
comes out like I'll do it and like we'll
know chill you're also going through
tunnels I think in the water I mean it's
scary but if if someone's in that
position I would want anything so it's
still good news more boys to go that's
pretty impressive how they decide who's
up I think based on who's the most
injured because some of them are injured
look and some of them are weaker and
some of them are not you know all that's
nice yeah a lot of [ __ ] mess
hopefully I'll get out safe man
the coach that took him under there now
when we bring you the health should we
all beat you and kick you in the nuts
exploring a storm hit and then it filled
up right so they couldn't get out yes
let's go deeper into the cave you might
have had to he's gonna get in trouble
for sure Oh hardcore he also got to be
charitable in this situation mistakes
happen to freak out for sure but don't
go on five hours you can't be a coach
anymore we gotta use can well no you can
be a kazakh coach just don't be a don't
be a cave guy now I just can't trust you
with kids anymore
unless you go Jim they said that those
kids have done that like many times past
you know like this is like not even the
furthest they've been before but just
the monsoon came and just changed
everything
yeah yeah come on to throw a wrench in
the old plan don't do that anymore okay
the last one this is just a report that
when uh before that North Korean summit
with Kim jong-un and Donald Trump
apparently Trump order Pompey to give
Kim jong-un an Elton John CD the one
that says Rocket Man any autographs by
him that's hilarious
it is pretty hilarious it's Adam Elton
John city buddy remember how many times
you made fun of him calling Rocket Man
yeah and then he gave him the CD I love
it I can barely talks with John Campea
didn't go so well they were regrettable
because America is making gangster
demands gangster anime extra demands
editor that's it well Brennan another
podcast another day I wanna thank you
for your leopard shoes leopard tiger
zebra cheetah
those are cow those are outraged cow see
the talons yeah those are the new Nikes
or what are they no but those had to Oh
bro those dopes are those what the kids
cool right here's our terrible you love
to decorate your feet
yours are terrible well mine are just
regular they're Pegasus but they can
come to you where the business sucks and
then you hike it up you know psoriasis
yeah I got some issues
hey you're making fun of my looks dude
you're making fun of my condition still
get a figure yeah all my friends are
such my friends and biggest [ __ ] my
friends like nobody has any sympathy
they're like they make fun of my
psoriasis yeah I feel like my own fault
Frank Frank posted a picture of himself
on Instagram and I called him Johnny
I called Giovanni hot-smoked and he went
after my psoriasis a media yeah he's a
so they just went after him it's pretty
easy Jesus guys yeah it's pretty easy
these days still gotta figure out your
outfit for your special right now which
is next week is that next thing now
that's on the 20th that's two weeks soon
no that's next week bro no this this
weekend I go to Syracuse in this weekend
this week I think
Gotham's already sold that guy sorry but
I got the funny bone Friday Saturday to
Saturday Friday Saturday and then and
then Thursday the 19th we have been at
Tahoe it's next week right that's next
week
that's what I mean this week I have that
and next week you gonna smoke in the
next week I'm in Chicago
Wednesday Los Angeles Wednesday I'm at
the Venice town house downstairs Braun
Braun's a room amazing room you got to
do that room [ __ ] it's great the
comments on Wednesday night I'm also at
the Comedy Store to z' day I'm doing Sam
trebly show I think we're there Tuesday
and Wednesday
yeah I think so 17th 17th I am I am wait
is the 17th or is it the 18th is the
18th might be the 17th or 18th we leave
Wednesday the 18th I am at the Venice
underground July I'm doing my one hour
there I'm practicing it yeah down there
for one hour starting at about 10:00 and
then I will fly to Chicago in the next
morning with you and we will do our show
at Tally Hall Oh Thursday and then
Friday we should then Friday's to shoot
so I'm excited
boom I'm in Spokane this week Spokane
Thursday Friday Saturday spoke and
comedy club get your tickets now f @k
Tom and then the first two weeks of
August in Austin cap cities the fur
Suika Vargas second week I'm in Dallas
at us and improv get your tickets teef
at kake.com also 5:00 p.m. tonight
Pacific we're releasing the vintage
Metallica themed finding the kids shirts
and scooter boner shirts chief at
kake.com it's now yeah tickets now to
fetch Kate calm for shirts tickets
anything Brian Brendon related see you
guys next time there's a fire kid we're
out